[Musique]
ce soir maître splinter nous a confié
une mission très importante la cible est
de l'autre côté de la rue on doit agir
avec discrétion des ruses pour infiltrer
le monde des humains et récupérer
un paquet de nouilles un paquet Batman
tu remplis le garde-manger et Mickey tu
fais le plein de Junko souvenez-vous
aucun humain ne doit nous voir vous vous
rappelez pourquoi les humains sont la
vermines démoniaque de la terre il faut
les éviter il faut pas les saluer ils
adorent massacrer tout ce qui leur
ressemble pas interagir avec eux
je sais que c'est carrément un préjugé
mais c'est ce que papa nous a appris moi
je trouve les humains plutôt sympa
franchement Beyoncé
Yolo les gamers pizzaiolo qui font du
breakdance écoutez on pense tous que les
humains sont cools mais on a une mission
au boulot au boulot